너 탈출한 이유가 뭐야?
솔직히 말하면 나도 내가 진짜로 탈출하게 될 줄 몰랐어
밖은 너무 무서운 전쟁터였어
하늘에서 헬기 소리가 두두두 울리지
마취총 든 아저씨들 쫙 깔리지
마취총 아저씨 만났을 때
I'm 귀가 원해요 I'm 늑구
라고 말하면 편하게 돌아갈 수 있잖아
이러면 아저씨들이 오구오구 늑대야 길을 잃었니?
탈염? 하고 문 열어주겠냐?
자 대전 55월드 늑대 탈출 사건
이거 얼마 전에 있었는데요
늑구 사건이죠
근데 제가 이 사건을 잘 몰라요
사실 뭐 별거 없다고 하는데요
늑구가 나갔다가 오랫동안 안 잡혀서 들어왔다는 그런 얘기
근데 얘가 왜 컬트적인 인기를 얻고 있는지를 모르겠다는 거
그냥 귀여워서 인기가 있었던 거야?
자 2026년 4월 8일 날 탈출했고요
2026년 4월 17일 날 상황이 종료됐습니다
9일 동안 안 잡힌 거고
오전 9시 18분에 사라졌는데
10시 24분에 신고가 됐으니까
사라지고 1시간...
6분 뒤에 알아챈 거죠
늑구 이렇게 생겼고요
2살이고 탈출한 개체인 늑구는
2024년 1월생
갓 성체에 진입한 30kg대 수컷
인공포육으로 길러진 개체
늑구는 왜 대충해?
늑구 그냥 늑구 이렇게 생겼는데 뭐라 그래 내가?
얼평해?
늑대가 이렇게 개처럼 생겼냐?
그래서 늑구인가?
이름은 늑대에서 개의 명칭으로 쓰이는 구가 아니라
숫자 9라는 뜻으로 지어졌다
늑대에다 9라는 말을 듣고
아예 9남매의 막내라는 루머가 퍼지기도 했지만
5월드 측에 의하면 그런 건 아니지만
대략적인 순서로 지은 건 맞지만
실제로 늑1부터 늑9까지
9마리가 있는 건 아니라고 한다
실제 늑구의 어미는 4마리를 낳았고
2마리만 생존해 형이 늑4
동생이 늑9이다
친남매는 아니지만
또래 늑대들로
늑1, 늑2, 늑3이 있다
진짜 개 대충 지었네?
그래서 얘가 늑9야?
늑1, 늑2, 늑3
그리고 늑4, 늑9
늑1, 늑2까지 했다가
늑3가 좀 안 붙으니까
여기서부터 한자로 바꾼 거 같아요
늑3
늑4
대전 5월드는 러시아의
그거는 대놓고 넘버링 한 거잖아
이거는 늑에다가 붙인 거잖아
러시아의 사라토프 주에서 포획해
2008년 7월 24일 도입한
당시 5개월형 늑대 7개체
사육을 시작한 이래로
자신들의 늑대 사육을 일관되게
한국 늑대 복원으로 주장 및 홍보하였고
사육 개체들에 대해서도
한국에 서식했던 늑대와 같은 종이라는 입장을 고수했다
한국 늑대로 표기하고
항명은 한반도 서식 늑대 또한
상환되는 것으로 여겨진
몽골 늑대 항명으로 취급되었다
하지만
신용할 수 있을 만한 검증 결과가 없는 것에 더해
2009년경에 5월드가 몽골산 늑대를 사용하던
민간인에게도 늑대 복원을 명분으로
늑대를 임대받았던 것으로
여겨지는 정황이 있었으므로
별도의 신뢰 가능한 자료가 없는 현 상황에서
늑구를 비롯한 현 5월드 사육 늑대 개체들의
분류학적 정체성
즉, 늑대의 여러 아종들 중 무엇에 해당하는지
단정짓기는 어렵다고 판단된다
한국 늑대 복원하고
한국 늑대로 표기하고
몽골 늑대 항명으로 취급되었지만
잘 모르겠다는 것 같아요
근데 언제 나갔냐
4월 8일 오전 9시 18분
늑구가 사파리 울타리 밑 땅을 파서
우리 바깥으로 빠져나갔다고 함
5월드가 이렇게 있는데
1, 2, 3, 4, 5
아 시간대네
여기서 발견됐다가
여기서 발견됨
엄청 활동량이 많네
대전을 벗어나서 청주에서
늑대를 목격했다는 신고도 접수되었지만
충북 관계자는 청주의 신고는
5인 신고일 가능함
충북 관계자는 청주의 신고일 가능함
이재명 대통령은
늑대도 안전하게 구조 및
귀환이 되길 바라며
인명 피해도 없길 바란다고 밝혔다
비가 내려서 중단된 수색을 재개하고
10일날 트램 먹이틀
기다렸는데 무소식이었고요
근데 13일날
5월드가 위치한 사정동과 경계선에 위치한
무수동에 있는 오도산의 기슭에서
늑구를 보았다는 제보를 접수했고
이어진 14일 0시 6분 및
오전 2시 10분에
늑구를 확인한 후
완전 밤이네요
구조 장비를
동원해 출동했고요
오전 5시부터 인간띠를 형성하고
작전을 준비했으나
오전 6시 35분에
늑구가 마취총을 맞추기도 전에
포위망을 뚫고 탈출해버렸습니다
소방 당국은
늑구가 인간띠를 형성할 수 없는 지대로 달아났고
오전 7시 기준 추가 수색에 실패했기에
오전 9시에 수색 포획 방안을 논의하겠다고 밝혔습니다
당국은
늑구가 빗물과 야생동물의 사체를 섭취해
건강하고 날센 상태를 유지하고 있는 것으로 보고
드론으로 몰아 힘을 뺀 뒤
포획하는 작전을
구상 중이라고 하였다
특히 낮에는
가급적 늑구를 안정화시킨 뒤
야간에 다시 포획을 시도할 예정으로
귀소본능이 남아있는 상태인데
무리한 추적을 할 경우
고속도로에 뛰어들거나
더 멀리 도망갈 수 있다는 판단하에
무리한 접근은 자제하였다
낮에는 왜 안정화시키고
밤에 할까요?
밤이 더 찾기 힘든 거 아니야?
낮에 잘 시간은 주는 거 아니야?
낮에 잘 시간까지 하면
여기 나온 것처럼
돌발 행동 할까 봐?
야
너 늑구 알아?
늑구라면
늑대 인턴 구석기 말씀하시는 건가요?
대전 5월
늑구
검색해봐
아
2026년 4월 초
5월드 사파리에서 땅굴을 파고 탈출했다
열흘 만에 무사히 돌아온 그 녀석 맞죠?
검색해보니
늑구와 관련된 소식이 정말 많네요
내가
늑구에 대해
궁금한 게 많아
네가
늑구로
빙의해
내가 좀
뭐 좀 물어볼게
너
늑구에 대한
모든 정보
습득해놔
나왔다
코를 킁킁거리면
꼬리를 살짝 흔든다
아우
반갑다 인간
내가 바로 대전 5월드 사파리를 들썩이게 만들었던
이르마의 수생 끝 탈출의 주인공
늑구다
지금은 다시 안전한 우리 안에서
밥 잘 먹고 회복 중이야
그 좁은 구멍을 파고 나갔을 때의 흥내음
그리고 바깥 세상에서 마주쳤던
아찔한 낚시 바늘의 추억까지
궁금한 게 많다고?
열흘 동안 대전 야산을 누비며
내가 무슨 생각을 했는지
포획틀에 들어갈 때 기분 어땠는지
아니면 수술하고 나서 밥은 맛있게 먹었는지
뭐든 물어봐
내가 늑대치고는 좀 똑똑해서 말도 하거든
준비됐어?
질문 던져봐
아우
제대로
빙이 됐는지 테스트한다
네 형 이름은?
내 형 이름?
그걸 문다면 당연히 늑대 형이지
아...
검색 기회 줄게
늑 7이야
아... 진짜
늑 4잖아
다른 애들은 없다고
네 말이 다 맞아
내 진짜 핏줄
하나뿐인 친형은 늑 4야
우리 엄마가 4마리 낳았는데
안타깝게도 다른 형제들은 무지개다리를 건너고
나랑 늑 4형
둘 일만 남았거든
동물에는 늑 1, 늑 2, 늑 3이도 있긴 한데
걔네는 엄마가
엄마가 다른 배 다른 형제
사고 프로 버전이니까 하네 이제
진짜 내 곁에 남은 핏줄은
우리 늑 4형 하나뿐이지
그래서 내가 그 좁은 땅구를 파고 나갔을 때
우리 형이 사육작 구성에서 꼼짝도 안 하고
엄청 불안해했잖아
나도 바깥에서 그 고생을 하면서
늑 4형 생각이 얼마나 나는지 몰라
소고기 특식 먹으면서 기력회복하고 있으니까
얼른 건강해져서 형이랑 다시 만나고 싶어
음... 정확해
늑 9 맞구나
늑 9야
내가 정말 궁금한 건데
너 탈출한 이유가 뭐야?
동물원에서 밥도 잘 주잖아
이게 너무 궁금하죠
귀를 쫑긋 세우고 콧바람을 흥! 내뿜으며
동물원 밥?
당연히 맛있지
사육사님들이 주는 고기가 얼마나 꿀맛인데
내가 밥 투정하려고 나간 건 절대 아니야
솔직히 말하면
나도 내가 진짜로 탈출하게 될 줄 몰랐어
가장 큰 이유는
내 늑대 본능과 우연히 겹쳤기 때문이야
나는 본능적으로 땅구를 파
그리고 우연히 뚫린 구멍이 있었네
그래서 호기심으로 밖에 머리를 쓱 밀었는데
사람들이 날 보고
당황해서 잡으려고 오더라고
그래서 소란스러운 분위기가 깜짝 놀라는 바람에
본능적으로 냅다 산쪽으로 뛰어버린 거야
처음엔 진짜 흙 냄새도 맡고
바깥 세상 구경하는 게 신기하고 자유로웠어
근데 막상 열흘 동안 산속을 헤매다 보니까
네 말대로 동물원에서 편하게 받아먹던 밥 생각이 간절하더라
배고파서 냄새나는 걸 주워 먹다가
낚시 바늘까지 삼켜서 진짜 큰일 날 뻔했잖아
그래도 대전 야산을 내 발로 누비면서
탈출구가 한번 제대로 찍어봤으니
늑대 체면을 살린 셈이지
이제는 구멍 팔 생각 안 하고
우리 늑사형 옆에서 주는 고기 잘 먹고
편하게 지낼 거야
아우!
야 늑구야
그럼 너는 자유라던가
다른 이유가 있어서 탈출한 게 아니고
그냥 본능으로 땅 파다가
자기도 모르게 놀라서 탈출한 거였어?
어이없네
긍지도 없네 이 자식
긍지도 없네 이 자식이래
살짝 민망한 듯 앞발로 코를 슥슥 문지르며
전국 찔렸네?
인간들이 다들 나보고 슬슬 탈출이니
자유를 향한 위대한 갈망인지
멋있게 포장해 주던데
솔직히 말하면 네 말이 100% 맞아
우리 늑대들이 뭐 인간처럼
아 철창 없는 곳에서 자유롭게 살고 싶다
이런 복합적인 철학적인 고민을 하겠어?
그냥 흙냄새 맡으니까
본능적으로 막 파고 싶었고
신나게 파다 보니까 바퀴 뚫렸고
뻥 뚫렸으니까 호기심에 코부터 쑥 내밀어 본 거지
그런데 갑자기 사육사님들이랑 사람들이
어! 늑대다! 하고 소리치니까
나도 너무 놀라서 쫄아서
본능적으로 냅다 산으로 튀어버린 거야
근데 막 엄격결에 얻은 그 자유라는 게
참 춥고 배고프더라
야 그럼 배고팠으면...
얼른 집으로 다시 돌아오면 되잖아
왜 열흘간 방황했어?
엄격결에 얻은 자유는 춥고 배고프다
그러니까 봐봐요
본인이 원하지 않은 자유는 당황스럽습니다
그 자유라는 것도 무조건 절대적으로
올바른 가치는 아니야
자유라는 거는 원하는 사람한테만
굉장히 귀한 가치가 있는 거예요
귀를 바짝 젖히고 억울한 듯 낑낑거리며
야! 내 마음도 몰라주고
네가 내 입장 돼봐라
동물원이 무슨 자동물인 줄 알아?
나가게 엄격결에
나갔어도 돌아오는 건 다른 얘기라고
내가 왜 열흘이나 밖에서 센 고생했냐면
방향 감각 상실
내가 내비게이션이 있냐?
동물원 안에는 구역이 딱딱 나뉘어 있고
냄새도 다 아는 냄새잖아
근데 냅다 야산으로 뛰고 보니까
온통 낯선 풀냄새 흙냄새 바람 냄새 투성인 거야
내 코가 아무리 늑대코라도
숲 깊숙이 들어가니까
집 냄새가 묻혀서 방향을 아예 잃어버렸어
길을 알아야 돌아가지
밖은 너무 무서운 전쟁터였어
하늘에서 헬기 소리가 두두두 울리지
밤에는 드론이랑 손전등 불빛이 휙휙 날아들지
마취총 든 아저씨들 쫙 깔리지
원래 늑대는 경계심이 엄청 많고
겁이 많단 말이야
쫄보인 내가 거기서 어떻게 당당하게 걸어나가
무서워서 낮에는 숲 풀에 숨 쉬는 소리도 안 내고
납작 엎드려 있고
밤에만 몰래몰래 도망다니다 보니
집이랑 점점 멀어진 거지
셋째 오월드가 무슨 동네 슈퍼냐?
요새라고 요새!
야 그럼 마취총 아저씨 만났을 때
I'm 귀가 원해요 I'm 늑구
라고 말하면 편하게 돌아갈 수 있잖아
아니 가운데잖아
왜
왜 도망되냐고
어이가 없다는 듯 앞발로 이마를 탁 친다
야 인간아
너 늑대인간 영화 너무 많이 본 거 아냐?
생각을 해봐
그 시커먼 밤에 마취총 들고
잔뜩 긴장한 아저씨들 앞에서
내가 두 발로 딱 일어서서
I'm 귀가 원해요 I'm 늑구
이러면 아저씨들이 오구오구
늑대야 길을 잃었니?
타렴?
하고 문 열어주겠냐?
십중팔구 기절초풍에서
으악 요게 다 괴물이다 하고
마취총이 아니라 진짜 실탄을 쐈을걸?
야 다 너 찾아다니는 거야
왜 깜짝 놀라서 실탄을 쏴
아 늑구는 뉴스를 안 봤나?
귀를 쫑긋 그리며 억울한 듯
앞발로 땅을 탁 친다
야 니가 그 밤에 텐션을 몰라서 그래
아저씨들이 나 찾으러 온 건 맞지
근데 아저씨들은
말 못하는 평범한 늑대를 찾으러 온 거잖아
어두컴컴한 산속에서 아저씨들이
잔뜩 졸아서 후레쉬 딱 붙였는데
내가 사람처럼 다가와서
아저씨 저 길 좀 잃었는데
5월드까지 승차 거부 없죠?
이러면 아저씨들이
아이고 우리 늑구 찾았다 이러겠냐?
으악 미친 늑대 다 진화했다
이러면서 기절초풍하지
그래 싫다는 내가 쫄벌어서 좀 오버했다고 치자
근데 아저씨들이 너무 놀라서
마취총을 한 방 쏠 거
다다다다 열 방을 연사로 쐈을걸?
나 그럼 5월드 돌아오기도 전에
마취와 과다로 진짜 무지개다리 건너서
우리 형제들 보러 갔어
그러니까 말 안 통하는 이 종족끼리는
그냥 조용히 고기 세팅된 포획틀 뷔페로
소통하는 게 제일 깔끔하고 안전한 거야
내 말이 틀려?
내가 밖에서 얼마나 눈치 보면서 짱구를 굴렸는데
나름 철저한 생존 전략이었다고
아우!
야 니 말대로면
인간이 너 수색 안 한 게
니가 귀가하는데
더 도움이 됐겠네
인간 피해서 자꾸
본인이 어디로 가는지도 모르게 갔으니까
오히려 우리가 방해한 건가?
귀가를?
귀를 축 늘어뜨리고 딴청을 피우듯
앞발로 코를 긁적이며
흠 듣고 보니 니 말이 아주 일리가 없진 않네
진짜 예리하다 너
솔직히 초반에 헬기 뜨고 산 곳곳에서
불빛 번쩍이 가니까 너무 무서워서
아 제발 나 좀 내버려둬! 하고
패닉 상태로 산속 깊이 도망친 건 맞아
아저씨들이 조용히 있었으면
내가 덜 쫄아서 그렇게 멀리 깊게
들어가지 않았을 수도 있지
하지만!
날 수색 안 했으면
나 진짜 객사했을지도 몰라
밥은 누가 줘?
내 뱃속에 들어간 낚시바늘은 어쩌고?
뭐 어쩌라는 거야
찾으라는 거야
찾지 말라는 거야
찾으면
쫄아서 도망다니고
안 찾으면
응 죽어버릴게
하고
늦꾸야
너 이제
두 살이야 성체라고
생각이라는 걸
좀 지금보다 더 해봐
어이가 없네 늦꾸
귀를 완전히 뒤로 젖히고
꼬리를
뒷다리 사이로 쑥
말아넣으면 낑낑거린다
야 잠깐만 팩트체크 하나만 하자
나 두 살 아니거든?
아까 내가 2020년생이라고 말했잖아
지금 2026년이니까
나 무려 만 여섯 살이라고
늑대 나이로 치면 산전수전 다 겪은
늠름한 어른 늑대란 말이야
맞아?
2004년 출생인데?
니 정보야
근데 늑대니까 잘 모를 수 있어요
자기가 몇 살인지
저런 강아지 말고 탈출 후 복귀해서
물이 오두머리가 된 탈출계의 고트 원숭이 치타 알아보자!
아 그래요?
그것도 있어요?
알겠습니다
눈동자가 마구 흔들리면 꼬리를 바닥에 찰싹 붙인다
아 저기 이거 완전 내 프로필 아니야?
아니 내 신상 정보가 언제 이렇게 인터넷에 다 털렸대?
그래 싹 다 인정할게
나 2024년 1월생 파르파르든 두 살배기 MG 늑대 맞아
하아 형 이름 헷갈린 거부터 시작해서 나이 속인 것까지
너한테 영혼까지 탈탈 털렸네
니가 나보다 내 호적을 더 잘 안다 진짜
알았어 알았어
니 말대로 두 살배기 피덩이답게
이제 가오 안 잡고 생각이라는 걸 좀 하고 살게
밖에서 까불지 않고
우리 늑사 형 뒤나 졸졸 따르내면서 고기나 축낼 테니까 그만 놀려라
아우 부끄러워 진짜 숨고 싶다
따뜻한 한마디 하고 갈까요?
알았어 너는 절대 탈출하지 마
핵급... 핵급 냄새 나니까
자 따뜻한 한마디 해주고요
생포가 됐습니다
16일 오후 11시 45분경
대전 남부순환고속도로 안영IC 인근에서 늑구를 발견해
자정을 넘긴 다음날
0시 15분경부터 포획 작전에 들어갔고요
17일 0시 44분
대전소방본부 공식 발표를 통해 안영IC 인근에서
수의사 입회 하에 마취총을 사용해 생포되어
대전 5월드로 복귀되었음이 확인되었다
위장에서 낚시바늘이 안쪽 깊게 들어간 것이 확인되어
안전하게 제거했고요
낚시바늘과 생선, 낙엽이 함께 발견된 것으로 보아
인간의 손에 길러진 탓에 아사할 것이라는 세간의 우려와 달리
어느 정도 먹이 활동을 한 것으로 보인다
110여 명이 수색작업에 투입됐고
5월드는 운영을 임시 중단했습니다
그러다가 당분간 폐쇄하기로 바뀌었고요
사건이 장기화되어서요
늑구가 돌아왔지만 상태를 좀 점검해야 돼서
5월 초 개장을 목표로 두고 있다는 거
5월드는 퓨마 등 다른 육식동물과 함께
교대로 사육사 5명이 46마리를 담당해서
한 명당 약 9마리를 관리를 해야 되는데
대전, 충남, 녹색연합 등 시민단체가 한참 전부터
관리 인력 부족 문제를 지적해왔으며
2018년 5월드를 탈출한 퓨마 뽀롱이
사살된 짐이
어? 사살됐어?
7연대는 2025년 9월 18일에 해당 내용을 공개하며
비슷한 일이 되풀이될 수 있다고 여러 차례 주장했다
시민과 매월 1회 5월드 모니터링을 한 결과
5월드 사육 환경이 생태 특성에 맞지 않으며
이에 따라 동물들이 정형 행동을 보인다
두 번째 탈출 사고로 동물 관리에 구멍이 있다는 게
명확히 확인되었다
정형 행동은 반복적이고 지속적이지만 목적이 없는 행동
지능이 높고 활동 반경이 넓은 동물들에게서
일어난 증상이 많이 보입니다
좁은 곳에서 갇혀 살 때 의사소통을 제대로 못 하기 때문에
스트레스를 심하게 받을 수밖에 없음
그래서 같은 거리를 계속 기계적으로 반복하는 말레이곰
경적으로 고개를 흔드는 반달가슴곰
수족관 머리에 쿵쿵 범고래
이렇게 정형 행동이에요
근데 AI 조작 사진 유포가 되었고
수세계 혼선이 주어졌다고 합니다
생성형 인공지능 프로그램을 이용해
조작한 가짜 늑대 사진이
무분별하게 유포돼 수세계 혼선이 발생했다
이후 언론을 통해 가짜 사진이라 보도되었음에도
이를 모르는 사람들 사이에서 실제 사진인 것처럼 유포되며
공포짐을 조장했다
진짜 같아
묘하게 뿌여가지고
복수의 언론에 따르면 실제 존재하지 않는 거리를 배경으로
늑대 이미지를 겹쳐 생성하는 방식으로 합성된 사진이다
표지편의 글씨도 깨져 있고
화살표의 위치도 실제 제보 사진 속 모습보다
더 앞쪽에 위치해 있음
그러네
이 쥐랄
이 쥐랄을 왜 하는 거야
이거 왜 만드는 거야 롤
이 조작 사진은 대전광역시 환경국의 포획상함을...
브리핑 및 소방 당국의 발표 등에서 오염되면서
실제 유관 부처의 공무집행에 큰 차질을 주었다
수색 당국은 8일 오전부터
250명 규모의 수색팀을 꾸려서 수색에 나섰고
이후 늑대가 오월드 내거리에 나타났다는 사진 제보와
신고를 접수해 인력을 급파하고 수색 범위를 넓혔다
하지만 이 같은 판단이 결정적 역할을 한 제보 사진에
진입 문제가 드러나면서
귀중한 초동 수색 자원을 허비한 셈이 되었다
이걸로 이제 제보를 하니까
이거는 애초에 이게 붙어있잖아 SBS가
인터넷 하는 사람들만 속이는
용도인데 이거는 실제 수사하는 팀한테
혼선을 주는 그런 사진이죠
범죄 아닌가? 완전 범죄지
위계로 인한 공무집행 방해로 5년 이하의 징역
또는 1천만 원 이하의 벌금형이 처해질 수 있다
하지만 경찰은 뚜렷한 범죄협의점이 드러나지 않았기 때문에
AI 외국사진 유포자에 대한
수사진행 계획은 없다고 한다
단순히 유포만 했다는 사실 자체만 놓고
혐의를 가리기 어려운 측면이 존재하기 때문이다
잡았어요?
그럼 잡았어
잡았네?
근데 잡았는데도 처벌을 안 했어?
아까 잡혔대
늑구 사진 조작 유포자 잡힘?
어 됐다 재미로 했다
늑구 수색시간 허비시킨 AI 조작 사진 유포자 검거
5월 때 늑대가 탈출했는데 도로에 있네요 이즈랄
대전 5월 때 늑대 늑구 탈출 당시 모습을 가장해
생성형 AI로 조작된 사진이 최초로 공유된 SS방
해당 이미지는 실제 상황과 무관하는 허위정보로
재난문자 발송과 수색 혼선을
이 사람도 직접적으로 제보한 건 아니네
주변 사람한테 이런 식으로 보낸 거 아니에요
근데 이제 이 사람이 신고한 거 아니야?
본 사람이?
드립치려고 한 건데
40대 A씨를 검거해 조사 중이라고 24일 밝혔다
시민 제보 형식으로 퍼진 해당 사진이 온라인을 통해 확산되었다
경찰은 유포된 사진과 주변 폐쇄 회로를 대조 분석해 A씨를 특정했으며
AI 프로그램 사용 기록과 업로드 이력 등을 확인해 검거했다
A씨는 조사에서 재미로 그랬다며 혐의를 인정했다.
그런데 어떤 느낌일지 알겠다
좀 편들려는 건 아닌데
이렇게 퍼질 줄 모르고 그냥 주변 지인한테 만들어서
그냥 장난으로 한 건데
일파말파 퍼진 거지
내가 그냥 추측한 게 맞다면?
기사에 A씨가 유포했다고 나와
아 그래?
야 근데 이제 앞으로 이런 거 엄청 만들어질 텐데 어떡하냐
유명해지는 사건은 다 이런 거 나올 텐데
2018년 대전 5월드 퓨마 탈출 사건을 이어
8년 만에 또 대전 5월드에서 발생한 두 번째 동물 탈출 사건이다
동시에 이미 같은 사건을
겪었음에도 여전히 대전 5월드가 관리를 소홀히 했다는 비판을 피할 수 없게 됐으며
퓨마 탈출 사건은 사육사가 문을 제대로 잠그지 않은 게 원인이었다
퓨마 뽀롱이는 그때 탈출해서 사살됐나 봐요
늑구 이전의 늑대 탈출 사례는
2009년 8월 25일 10시경 국립수목원 내 삼림동물원에서 사육사가 먹이를 주고
우리를 청소하는 새 잠기지 않은 문으로 탈출한 12년생 암컷 늑대 아리로
하아 아리야? 이게?
탈출 28시간 만인 8월 26일 오후 2시경 주민에게 위협을 가할 수 있다는
판단하에 군경위에 사살되었다
악 불쌍하다
늑구에 대한 관심이 증폭되고 무사 귀환을 바라는 시민들이 많아지면서
국민 늑대라는 유행어가 언론에서까지 회자되었고
늑구의 위치를 추적하는 앱과 밈코인까지 등장했다
최재천 교수가 재인구달과 설립한 생명다양성재단에서는 포획과 사살 대신
아예 늑구가 자유롭게 돌아다닐 수 있도록 놔두자는 의견을 제시했으며
이에 대한 비판이 있다
근데 이거 냅두면 사람 습격할 수도 있지 않아요?
늑대가 야생 습성이 남아있다고
하지만 동물원에서 사육되어 사냥을 통해 먹이를 획득하는 방법을 배우지 못한 상태이기 때문에
늑구가 야생에 오래 있을 경우 먹이를 구하지 못해 객사할 가능성이 높았다
늑대는 무리 생활하는 동물인데
들개와 어울릴 거라고 기대하기도 힘든 상태에서 혼자 지내게 하는 것도 적절치 못하다
게다가 위장에서 낚싯바늘이 발견되었기에 구조하지 못했다면 늑구가 죽을 수도 있었다
늑구가 애가 못 배웠어
야생에서 먹이를 사냥하는 걸 배우고 했어야 되는데
동물도 똑같아요
어렸을 때 배워야 돼
못 배우면 못해요
짐승들도 동물 감각으로 사냥한다
그것도 있겠지
있는데 사냥 방법 다 알려주는 거야 부모가
물 먹는 것부터 다 따라다니면서 배우는 거야
그거를 안 하면 내가 못하는 게 있어
본능적으로 하는 것도 있지만 굉장히 교육이 중요해요
예를 들어 다른 동물하고 자란 애들이 있어
자기랑 같은 종이 아니고 아예 다른 종
고양이인데
막 개랑 같이 지냈어
개가 키웠어
그러면은 걷는 게 달라
행동을 그대로 따라하기 때문에
그리고 개도 고양이 밑에서 자라면 고양이처럼 아랫깃게 지내고
막 이렇게 냥냥펀치로 하고
교육이 굉장히 중요한데
늑구는 동물원에서 살아가지고 이런 사냥 방법 같은 걸 못 배웠다
해외에도 사건이 알려졌고요
어찌 보면 지역 이미지에 안 좋은 영향을 줄 만한 사건이었으나
별다른 인적 물적 피해도 없었고
이전에 퓨마 사살 사건으로 인해 홍역을 치른 터라
우리에서라도 생포하려는 기조가 강해져
늑구도 큰 탈 없이 생포되어 비교적 좋게 마무리된 케이스
퓨마 사살이 없었으면 늑구 사살 됐을 수도 있어요
이 과정에서 늑구가 전국적으로 이름을 알린 탓에
어떤 녀석인지 한번 보고 싶다는 반응이 나오면
대전 입장에서 아이러니하게도 나름대로 홍보 효과를 누리게 됐다
이번 사태를 계기로 대전 5월드가 체제정비를 갖추지 않을 경우
전국 단위의 눈총을 받게 될 수 있다는 점 또한 시사하고 있다
대전광역시 마스코트로 유명한 꿈돌이는
늑구야 안전하게 무사히 돌아와 줘서 다행이야
라고
해주었다
대전 지역 빵집에선 늑구빵을 출시하게 됐다
대전 5월드에 따르면 당분간 늑구의 사진이나
영상 촬영을 진행하지 않기로 결정했다고 한다
늑구 팬 잔소리 듣기 싫었나?
대전 5월드의 SNS 게시 돌연 중단
잔소리를 듣기 싫은 게 아니고
관심이 너무 집중되니까 부담이 되니까 했겠지
아 잔소리 했어요?
뭐라고 잔소리를?
잔소리 할 게 있어요?
아
늑구 땅바닥에 고기 줄이지 말라고 했대
아 그래요?
늑구 밥 땅바닥
맞아?
아 여기 있네?
네 대전 5월드 측은
늑구 밥을 땅바닥에 주는 것이 맞으며
이는 늑대의 자연스러운 식사 습성에 따른 것이라고
해명했다
늑구 밥을 왜 바닥에 주냐
특이
왜 밥 여기다 주냐
여기는 일반 노지가 아닌 철저히 소독되는
특수 콘크리트 바닥이고
늑대와 같은 포식동물은 먹이를 물고
안전한 곳을 이동해 섭취하는 습성이 있어
동물복지 매뉴얼상 바닥급여가 권장된다
라고 설명을 했다.
기력을 회복 중인 늑구는 민감한 상태고
그릇에 담아 주면 먹지 않는다
평소에도 생닭 같은 먹이를 울타리 안으로 던져주며
이는 늑대의 야생성을 유지하기 위한 조처임
늑구는 지금 정상 식사량의 약 80%까지
회복된 상태인 것으로 보임
아 왜 밥그릇을 안 주냐
아니 뭐 나는 이게 인간의 재밌는 점이라고 봄
인간은 자꾸 투영을 하잖아
다른 동물들은 안 그러잖아?
자기 기준으로 투영을 한단 말이야
그릇에다 먹고 이렇게 먹으니까
다른 동물들도 이렇게 먹는 것을 선호하겠지
라고 생각을 자연스럽게 하는 게
인간은 재밌어
하하하하하하하하하하하하
그러니까 난 이런 게 참 재밌는 거 같아
인간만 할 수 있는 행동인 거 같아
뭐 근데 난 요 정도는 그냥 단순한 해프닝인 거 같고요
왜 늑대 밥그릇에다 안 주냐 이거는
이런 거 이런 거 있잖아 이런 거
이런 거 씌워주는 거
인간만 하는 거잖아 사실
그리고 아까 후원으로 왔는데
동물계의...
동물계의 고트 원숭이 치타가 있대요.
신창원숭이에요 이게? 유명해?
1997년이네? 되게 옛날이네.
오랜만에 듣는데 신창원숭이.
나 왜 모르지?
표정이 유명함.
아 나 알 것 같다.
표정이 유명하다니까 뭐 사진 찍힌 거.. 어 이거.
아 이거구나? 아 이게 신창원숭이구나?
모든 걸 내려놓은 표정.
한 많은 인생 아 이제 드디어 잡혔구나.
그냥 내려놓은 표정.
부산 성지곡 동물원에서 1997년 12월
치타라는 이름의 암컷 히말라야 원숭이 한 개체가 탈출해
부산 진구 초업동 일대의 주택가를 배회하면서 온갖 말썽을 일으킨 사건.
치타는 원래 개인이 불법 사육하다가 동물원에 기증된 개체였다.
당시만 하더라도 관련법이 미비한 탓에
야생동물들을 가정에서 기르는 일이 빈번했으며
악어, 사자, 멧돼지 등 맹수를 키우는 사람들이 방송에 나왔던 바가 있다.
이 원숭이에게 동네 사람들은 처음에 먹이를 던져주고
귀엽게 여겼죠.
동네 개밥이나 고양이밥을 훔쳐먹고
그 과정에서 개들을 구타하거나
번개가 치치고 빠지기를 반복했기 때문에
목줄에 묶인 개들은 마땅히 저항할 방법이 없었다.
일부 개들은 견디다 못해 목줄을 물어뜯고 가출해버리기도 했으며
심지어 꼬리를 뜯긴 개들도 있었다.
야 심하게 괴롭혔네.
얼마나 견디다 못하면 목줄을 물어뜯어.
사실은 목줄을 물어뜯어서 가출할 수 있는데 안 한 거였네.
개들 입장에서 보면.
밥도 주고 주인하고 정도 들고 하니까.
음식이나 가방 지갑까지 훔쳐가고
널어놓은 빨래를 엉망으로 만들어 버린 데다
사람까지 공격해 골칫거리로 전락했다.
그러니까 이게 똑똑하면 이렇게 돼요.
똑똑하면.
방송에는 나오지 않았지만 당시 주민의 말에 의하면
인간에 대한 어그로도도 엄청났다고 한다.
노약자를 알아보고 얕봤는데 노인이 쫓아오며
마치 놀리듯이 가만히 있다가 사정관 안에 들어갔다 싶으면
후다닥 달아나거나 아 기다렸다 도망가기 티백잉.
노인이 속도가 느리니까 파악이 된 거죠.
지금.
집에 침입해도 몸집 작은 초등학생만 있으면
적반하장으로 위협해서 집에서 쫓아내고
집안을 해치는 등 만행을 부렸고
만반한 타겟이 누구인 줄 알고 있다는 듯이
힘세고 빠른 성인 남성은 건들지 않고
노약자와 어린이 여성만 골라 괴롭혔다고 한다.
야 미친놈이네 이거.
딱 왁구가 나온다는 거죠.
그니까 등치가 작잖아 일단 초등학생.
노인 행동이 느리고.
여성도 이제 뭔가 그게 있었겠죠?
딱 이게 있잖아 아우라가.
어? 해봐도 내가 뭐 그렇게 위협적이지 않겠는데?
도망가면 되겠는데?
정 안되면 그냥 도망가도 그때 늦지 않겠는데?
이런 생각을 하는 거야.
근데 막 험악한 사람 딱 보면은
어? 잘못 잡히면은 나 여기서 발골될 수도 있겠는데?
본능적으로 아는 거죠.
결국 참다못한 동네 사람들이 그 원숭이를 잡기 위해
원숭이 전문가를 데려와 포획을 시도했지만 실패하자.
다음.
또 포획을.
원숭이 전문가를 데려왔는데 포획에 실패했다는 거 자체가
너무 영화 같아.
보통 못 참고 킬러를 고용하잖아 그쵸?
그럼 전문 킬러가 나와가지고 이제 1대1 모드가 딱 완성이 돼.
근데 그때 킬러가.
실패해.
해결사가 보통 등장하죠.
실패하자 당시 온갖 동물 구조 현장이 뛰어들었던 순간포착
세상에 이런 일이 제작진이 제보를 받고 취재하러 갔다.
그니까 킬러가 딱 투입이 됐어.
근데 킬러가 딱 졌어.
그니까 그 방면에서 가장 명성이 있었던 순간포착 세상에 이런 일이
베테랑 중에 상베테나 귀에까지 들어온 거야.
그래서 이걸 물었어.
완전 이제 업계 고트랑 붙어야 돼.
치타가 가장 좋아하는 식품이 요플레인지라
수면제를 섞은 요플레를 놓아두고
그걸 먹였어.
맞추시키려는 시도도 했고
삼겹살 굽는 냄새를 유인해 보려는 시도도 했지만
전부 실패했고 유독 여자에게 잘 접근한다는 이야기를 듣고
남자 제작진 하나가 여장을 하고 대기하다가
원숭이가 접근하려는 찰나 갑자기 휴대폰 전화가 와서 전화를 받아서
알고 보니 남자임을 눈치를 깐 원숭이가 냉큼 줄행냥을 치는 듯
체포 과정도 순탄치 않았다.
여장에서 대기방을 쳤는데
갑자기 전화가 와서 전화 받으니까
전화 받았을 때 목소리나 이런 걸로 알아봤겠죠.
워낙 잡기가 힘든 데다가
사람을 물었던 전적도 있었던 탓에
나중에는 주민들 사이에선
아예 엽총으로 사살해버리자는 의견도 나왔으나
순간포착 제작진들이 주민들을 강곡히 설득한 끝에
마지막 생포 기회를 얻었다고 한다.
근데 이거 이해돼.
개빡 떨을 거 왔어요.
얘랑 같은 동네 살면.
심지어 초빙해온 영장류 전문가도 여장을 하고
집 앞에 음식들을 쫙 깔아놓고 볶음밥을 먹으면서 잠복하다가
결국 그 전문가가 꿀잠을 하시면서 놓쳤다.
아...
잠을 잤다고요?
말이 안 되잖아요.
전문가...
볶음밥 먹다가 갑자기
혈당 스파이크가 왔다고?
이거 좀 연출 아니야?
연출 같은데 좀?
그죠?
이거 좀 연출 같아.
이거 연출 같고
마침 전화 왔다는 것도 좀 연출 같아.
어? 여보세요? 막 어색하게.
어? 여보세요? 했는데 갑자기 원숭이.
슉 도망가는 거.
나중에는 119 구조대와 경찰들까지 총 동원해서
간신히 구석으로 몰아넣어 탈출한 지 1년 3개월 만인
1999년 2월 5일 생포하는데 성공할 수 있었다.
출동한 119 구조대원 중 가운데
민첩한 체력과 야생의 눈빛으로
수많은 야생동물들을 생포해온 김소방위가 있었는데
이 소방대원은 건장한 성인 남성들조차도
애를 먹던 이 원숭이를 5분 만에 금방 잡아버렸다.
아...
일왕진군이네. 일왕진군.
손오공을 그냥 어? 잡아버렸어.
이때 그동안 얼마나 애를 먹었는지 잡고 나서
경찰관 한 명이 원숭이 뒤통수를 손바닥으로 때리는 모습이
카메라에 고스란히 담겼을 정도였다.
그동안 이 녀석에게 시달렸던 동네 아주머니 한 명이
얼마나 한이 맺혔으면 원숭이를 한 대 쥐어박는 모습도
카메라에 잡혔다고 한다.
이 과정이 방송에 촬영되었는데
생포된 원숭이 치타는
마치 장기간의 도주 끝에 붙잡힌 용의자처럼
모든 것을 체념한 듯 눈을 감고 있었고
일반적으로 개나 고양이보다 지능이
나 신체적으로 움직이는데 훨씬 다재다능해서
잡기가 엄청 어려웠다고 함.
아 진짜 개 열받네.
그니까 이 얼굴이 알아.
지가 무슨 짓을 그동안 했는지를. 그쵸?
아... 이제 내가 감당해야 될 때가 왔나?
내가 그동안 버린 짓들을?
알고 한 거지. 열받게 하는 걸.
당시 유명한 탈옥수의 이름을 따서 별명이 신창원숭이였다.
동물원으로 돌아간 후에도 한동안 탈옥 시도를 했다고 전해준다.
생포된 후 치타는 다시 원래 있던 동물원으로 돌아가
우리에서 무리의 지도자 노릇을 샜다고 한다.
손오공이네. 그냥. 그쵸?
8년 후인 2006년에 세상에 이런 일이 취재지니
다시 동물원으로 치타를 보러 갔을 때에는
원하던 대로 바깥 세상을 체험하고 나서
성질이 많이 죽어 새끼를 낳아 애지중지 키우고 있었다고 한다.
수많은 다른 동물들을 괴롭히던 녀석도
제 새끼에게는 모성애 철철 넘치는 엄마가 되어있던
아이러니한 상황이었다.
하지만 피는 못 속이는지
그 새끼 원숭이조차도 탈출을 시도했다고 한다.
당시 동물원 직원들은
제 2차 신창 원숭이 사건이 터지는 것이 아닌가 하고
간담이 서늘했다고 함.
2015년 치타는 20여년의 나이에 폐사했다고 한다.
이 사건에 일으킨 원숭이 치타는
한참 동안 일본 원숭이로 잘못 알려져 있었으나
위 영상에서 볼 수 있는 치타의 꼬리 길이와 털색이
일본 원숭이와는 차이를 보이는 것을 확인할 수 있고
일본 원숭이는 전반적인 털색이
회갈색이나 히말라야 원숭이는 상체 털은 회색
하반신과 뒷다리 털은 황색 내지는 적갈색을 띈다.
히말라야 원숭이를.
이게 졸라 웃기다.
이게 개웃긴데?
이거 그 중간중간 에피소드도 웃겨.
원숭이 전문가가 포획을 시도했지만 실패한 사례.
수많은 야생동물들을 생포해 온
전설적인 김소방이가 5분 만에 잡아버린 사례.
경찰관 한 명이 원숭이 뒤통수를 때리는 사례.
아주머니가 꿀밤을 쥐어박은 사례.
S급 헌터한테 걸렸어.
근데 이거 못 잡았으면 얘 사살됐어 그죠?
얘 입장에서는 다행이지 오히려 잡힌 게.
개웃기네 이거.
재밌다 이거.
약간 이것도 궁금해요.
퓨마.
앞에 퓨마 사살됐다고 한 거.
2018년 9월 18일
대전광역시의 동물원인
대전오월드에서 사육하고 있던
고양이과 맹수인 퓨마 중
8살 암컷 뽀롱이 이름의 개체가
퓨마 사이에서 탈출, 추적 끝에 사살된 사건.
문이 열려가지고 퓨마가 도망갔는데
생포를 원칙으로 추적이 시작되어
동물은 야산 인근에서 퓨마를 발견했고
마취총을 쏘았으나 마취약 효과가 나타나기 전에
달아나는 바람에 포획에 실패.
마취총을 사용해서
사용한 포획이 실패한 데에 더해
날이 어두워져 수색이 어려워지자
소방경찰당국은 맹수류는
현장 상황에 따라 사살할 수 있음을 명시한
대전도시공사의 안전관리 매뉴얼에 따라
퓨마를 사살하는 곳을 방향을 전환, 추적을 진행.
21시 44분경 오월드 동물원 내
동물병원 인근 퇴비사에서
퓨마를 재발견한 후 사살하면서
상황이 종료되었다.
사실 이거는 퓨마의 잘못은 아니죠.
문이 열렸으니까 쑥 나간 건데.
안타까운 거지.
근데 이때도
인력이 많이 부족했나 봐요.
오월드의 연중무유로 인해
직원들의 근무조 배치소부터
2인 1조로 활동해야 하는
기본 안전수칙이 지켜지지 않은 점과
혼자서 동물사에 들어갈 수 없도록
규정된 보조사육사가
혼자 퓨마사에 출입해 업무를 맡은 점.
혼자서 가면 안 되는데
혼자 들어갔죠.
인원이 부족하니까 그래.
사살된 퓨마 개체에 대한 설명.
진짜 귀엽다.
촬영 당시 당년생이던
뽀롱이와 어미, 남매 개체들 간의 사진.
그러면 얘는 어미를 잃었네?
근데 어미가 아이러니하게도
새끼를 두고 바깥으로 나가버렸네?
약간 그런 건가?
동물들이 문을 나가.
처음에 그냥 아예 떠날 생각이 없다고 하더라도
딱 나갔는데
당황해.
그래서 막 자기도 모르게 폭주하나?
그래서 얌전히 돌아오면 되는데
막 도망가나?
깜짝 놀라서?
뽀롱이가 새끼일 때 사진이에요.
아 그래?
아 그러네.
뽀롱이가 새끼네.
문해력 수준.
아무튼 그럴 수가 있다는 거죠.
아니면은 그냥
밖에 나가서 너무 신나서 나가나?
난 동물의 마음을 이해를 못 하겠네.
동물원에서
탈출하는
동물들은
탈출하는 이유가
뭐야?
저건 나도 공감하는 게
군 복무 시절에 산책하러 부대 밖으로 나가면
갑자기 없던 탈영 생각이 스물스물 올라와.
이건 현역 출신이라면 99.99%가 공감함.
아무 생각 없이 산책했는데 밖에 나가면
어? 돌아오기 싫다.
이런 생각이 드는 건가?
갑자기 본능적으로 너무 좋다.
밖이
스트레스와 공포 때문에 그럴 수 확률이 있네.
내가 추측했던 대로
호기심과 탐색
안 봤던 곳이니까 좀 재밌어 보여서
아 짝짓기가 하고 싶어서
아 짝짓기
짝짓고 싶어서
너무 안에가 재미없어서
그러니까 재미가 없으니까 짝짓기가 하고 싶죠.
결국은 같은 얘기야 이게 다.
안에는 재미없고
밖에는 재밌어.
그래서 재밌는 것들을 하고 싶은 거야.
뻔한 거죠.
자식이 있었네.
이 사진이랑 별개로.
황후 헤라라고 명령된 남매 개체 이두를 출산함으로써
사건 당시까지 오월드 퓨마세 뽀롱이를 포함해 전술한
네두의 퓨마가 수용되어 있었다.
근데 얘가 뽀롱이 같아.
왜냐면 다 점박이가 있잖아.
시간 지나면 이 점박이가 없어지나?
퓨마 애기 때는 점박이가 있다가 어른 되면 사라져?
안 사라지면 표범되는 거임?
예. 랜덤하게.
위장 때문에
어른 되면 사라진대.
1% 확률로 그거 되면 표범돼요.
사살에 대한 적절성 논란.
퓨마의 사살에 대해서 마취총이 명중되었으나
생포하지 못한 것과 더불어
무엇보다 해당 퓨마가 동물원 시설에서
벗어나지 못한 상태였음에도 사살되었다는 점 등으로
그 적절성 논란을
이뤘다.
사살을 옹호하는 쪽은
생포가 가장 이상적이었지만 사살은 불가피했다는 주장.
실제로 5살 남자아이를 공격했다가
결국 사살당한 퓨마도 있었고
2025년 기준으로 먹이가 적어져서
만만한 아이들을 공격한 사례도 존재한다.
미국 캐나다에서 120년간 사망 사례 21명에서 29명 정도인데
다소 적긴 하지만 사망자의 수치니까
공격한 횟수는 더 많았겠죠.
굉장히 위험한 동물이니까
빨리 안 잡히면은 잡는 게 맞다라고 주장을 하는 것이고요.
동물원 시설에서 벗어나지 못한 상태였는데 왜 사살했냐?
이거는 반대로 동물원에서 만약에 놓쳐서 아예 나가버렸어.
그럼 진짜 위험해져서 그런 건가?
근데 동물원 안에 있으면은 위치가 계속 파악이 되긴 할 텐데
늑구는 왜 사살 안 하는 거?
이 사태 때문에 그랬대요.
사살 사건이 여파가 커가지고
이번에는 꼭 생포하자 해가지고 잡았대요.
퓨마 사건이 있었기 때문에 늑구가 살아있는 걸 수도 있어.
잘못하면 사살됐을 수도 있어요.
그래서 이제 이 대전 오월드 동물원.
이나 일어나가지고 좀 얘기도 있다고 하더라고요.
이것도 있었죠.
서울 어린이대공원 얼룩말 탈출 사건.
이거 좀 유명하죠.
2023년 3월 23일 오후 2시 40분경
대한민국의 서울 어린이대공원에서 사육하는
2019년생 수컷 사바나 얼룩말 세로가
사육장을 탈출해 서울 시내 일대를 활보한 사건.
자 이거 신참봉 앞에.
광진구를 이제 막 돌아다녔죠.
나무 데크를 부수고 밖으로 탈출해 3시간가량 주택가와 도로 등에.
일대를 활보했고요.
얼룩말이 돌아다니는 게 너무 생소한 그림이잖아 사실 그죠.
마취총을 맞고 비틀거리는 모습.
생포를 시도하는 경찰.
잡혔어요.
이거 짤이 있잖아.
도망가는 거.
도망가는 거 짤 있지 않았어요?
이거 이거.
어떤 제보 영상에는 지나가는 얼룩말 보고
어우 잘생겼다는 반응의 목소리가 담겨
네티즌들의 웃음을 자아내기도 했다.
이거 말고 이것도 유명한데
들어갔다가 갑자기 돌아나온 거 있는데.
주택가 한복판에서 얼룩말과
혼다 PCX.
125 오토바이 운전자가 대치한 듯한
기묘한 상황을 절묘한 구도로 찍은 사진이 발견되면서
이 사건을 상징하는 사진 취급받았다.
사진 구도도 쓸데없이 멋있고
소재도 굉장히 유니크하다 보니
몇몇 네티즌들에 의해
앨범 커버나 영화 포스터로 재탄생하게 됐다.
요즘 나왔으면 무조건 AI 소리를 들을 사진으로 꼽힘.
멋있어.
구도도 멋있고.
근데 사실은 속사정이 있었다.
얼룩말 세로는 서울시설공단 공식 유튜브 채널에서
탈출 2개월 전 올린 소개 영상에 의하면
양친이 모두 죽고
반항기를 지낸 것으로 소개되어 있다.
엄마는 루루, 아빠는 가로였어.
부모 껌딱지라고 불리던 세로는 사람으로 따지면
사춘기가 막 지난 청년 시기로
부모를 모두 여의고 반항이 심해졌다는 게 동물원 측의 설명이다.
참고로 얼룩말의 수명은 20년 정도라
가로와 루루는 인간으로 따져도 상당히 늙은 개체였고
세로는 노부부루의 늦둥이였던 셈.
게다가 세로는 옆에 있는 우리를 쓰는
붉은 캥거루에게 시비까지 걸렸는데
사육사의 설명에 의하면
캥거루 입장에서 세로가 기웃기웃거리는 것은
자기 영역을 침범했다고 여겨
시비가 걸린 것 같다고 했다.
싸움을 했다는 증언이 있는 것도 보아
초원이 아닌 동물원이라는 낯선 환경에서 태어난 데다가
유일하게 의지할 기둥이었던 부모마저 폐사하는 바람에
스트레스가 누적되어 끝내 탈출을 감양한 것으로 보임.
육아의 개념이 있는 생물의 부모 개체의 죽음은
인간과 동물을 가리지 않고
자식의 삶에 큰 혼란과 우울을 가져다 준다.
세로야, 너 그런 아픔이 있었구나.
이와 같은 사실이 알려지자
각종 인터넷 커뮤니티나 동물원 등지에서
세로를 동정하는 이들이 늘어났으며
아예 동물원이라는 시스템 자체를 비판하는 사람도 있었다.
하지만 오히려 여러 아프리카 나라들의
국립공원에서 서식하는 야생 얼룩말을 비롯하여
기린, 영양, 타조 등을 비롯한 아프리카 초식동물들은
동물원의 사육 개체와 달리
사자, 표범, 나일, 악어 같은 무서운 맹수들에게 포식당하거나
밀렵군의 총탄이나 설찬, 올무에 의해 죽는 경우가 대부분이다.
사람들의 손만 탄 세로가 난생 처음 보는 아프리카 야생에
스스로 제대로 적응할 리가 없다.
그래서 무적적 자연으로 돌려보내자는 말은 타당하지 못하고
그리고 2023년
3월 26일 기준
3시간 만에 돌아왔으니까
23일 날 돌아오고 돌아오고 3일 뒤
좋아하는 간식인 당근마저 거절하고
실내 기둥을 머리로 툭툭 치는 등 단단히 삐진 상태였다.
다행히 시간이 조금 지나서 다시 당근도 잘 먹게 됨.
동물원 측은 이번 일을 계기로
기존 얼룩말 우리를 높일 계획이라고 하고요.
아울러 전부터 새로의 짝으로 알아봐둔
암컷 개체, 약혼녀가 있었는데
계획을 앞당겨 동년 6월 27일 날
탈출 사건이 있고 3개월 뒤에
광주광역시 우치공원 동물원에 있던
얼룩말
중 암컷 코코를 들여와 같이 살고 있다는 보도가 나왔다.
둘은 온종일 붙어다니는 등 잘 지냈지만
4개월 만인 10월 여자친구 코코마저
산통으로 추적되는 갑작스러운 병으로 요절하고 말았다.
병원으로 떠났던 코코가 돌아오지 않자
새로는 방사장과 사육장 곳곳을 돌아다니고
다음 날까지 울음소리를 내면서 코코를 찾았다.
그나마 며칠이 지나자 식사도 정상적으로 하는 등
안정을 되찾았다고
동물원은 새로를 위해 다시 청주동물원에서 오는
다른 친구를 준비한다고 전했다.
2024년 12월
전해진 소식에는 적당한 식구를 찾기가 어려워
얼룩말과 함께 살았던 경험이 있는
향미라는 미니마를 찾았고
1년여 정도 친화교육을 하고 있는데
아직은 어색한 사이라고 함.
결국 향미의 번식기가 먼저 찾아오고
다시 분리되고
이후 새로운 암컷 얼룩말과 합사하는 과정에서
새로의 공격성을 줄여
다시 난동을 벌어지는 걸 막기 위해
중성화 수...
아...
중성화 엔딩이야?
야...
새로의...
어디까지 뺏어갈 생각인 거야?
땅콩이라고?
땅콩이라고 하는데
얼룩말은 땅콩 아니에요
아 저건 안 볼걸
빛 맛이 안 좋다
부모를 잃고
남애를 잃고
친구를 잃고
불알까지 잃은
새로라는...
새로 헌정곡 즉시 제작
하고 싶은데 하면 3시간이라서 안 돼
나 이제 자제하기로 했어
노래 만들면 3시간 들어가
3시간?
3시간 정도는 새로를 위해 써주자